cuántos litros de refresco tenemos para
la fiesta y los invito a que ustedes
pausa en el vídeo y de acuerdo a la
información que tenemos aquí logremos
definir cuáles de estas nos pueden
servir o cuáles no para saber y
contestar cuántos litros de refresco
tenemos para la fiesta
empecemos entonces tenemos la primera
que nos dice que 20 personas vendrán a
la fiesta realmente eso no nos dice nada
de los litros que ya tenemos para la
fiesta así es que eliminaremos este
enunciado nos dice que compramos 5
botellas de refresco para la fiesta o
que esto sí es información tenemos una
y cinco botellas
esta información si nos funciona tenemos
5 botellas vamos a marcarla como
información importante
y con ello hemos marcado también
nuestras cinco botellas la fiesta durará
tres horas esto realmente tampoco nos da
información sobre los litros que tenemos
de refresco y ya tenemos información de
cuántas botellas solo necesitamos saber
cuántos litros contiene cada botella y
de hecho la siguiente información nos
dice que cada botella contiene todos los
litros de refresco esto también es
información importante así es que
tenemos las cinco botellas y cada
botella tiene dos litros de refresco
vamos a pensar dos litros aquí dos
litros aquí dos litros aquí dos litros
aquí y 2 litros aquí de hecho podemos
pensarlo de la siguiente manera tenemos
botellas
por 2 litros cada botella cada botella
contiene todos los litros estaremos
poniendo 5 botellas por 2 litros de cada
una y con esto tendremos nuestra
respuesta que significa este 5 por 2
significa que nosotros vamos a tener 5
veces 5 veces el número 2 estos a nivel
números 2 más 2 más 2 más 2 más 2
sumaremos entonces
este 25 veces o haremos la
multiplicación de 5 por 2 y si hacemos
eso tendremos dos más 24 26 28 2 10
10 litros tenemos litros
o lo que es lo mismo 5 por 2 será igual
a 10 litros de la misma manera así es
que tenemos ya la información incluso
sin haber llegado al último de nuestros
datos en el cual nos dice que 6 botellas
de refresco fueron usadas en el día de
campo de la semana pasada realmente esto
tampoco era información relevante para
contestar la respuesta de cuántos litros
de refresco tenemos para la fiesta ahora
sabemos que tenemos 10 litros totales
para la fiesta